[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys jetzt
wird es so langsam wieder wärmer das
heißt wir können auch nach draußen gehen
und grillen okay die hardcore griller
unter euch können wahrscheinlich auch an
kälteren tagen da gehöre ich definitiv
nicht dazu ich brauche erst warmes
wetter um nach draußen zu gehen und wird
grillen ganz gerne hamburger und dann
für mich gibt es nichts schlimmeres als
richtig tolle hamburger zu machen und
gekaufte bands dazu zu geben das heißt
heute zeige ich euch in meinem kleinen
basic video wie ich die bürger bank
selber herstellen
die sind wirklich super lecker und wenn
er jetzt sagt das ist mir viel zu viel
aufwand dann macht es doch einfach so
wie ich bereitet einmal richtig große
menge zu fried sie ein und bei bedarf
könnt ihr dann immer wieder die bürger
bei uns rausholen und eure leckeren
burger richtig frisch grillen ich zeige
euch jetzt einfach mal kurz die zutaten
für die bäcker brötchen brauche ich
einen würfel frischhefe 200 milliliter
lauwarmes wasser 30 gramm zucker 30
gramm zuckerrübensirup 260 gramm butter
milch vier teelöffel salz zweier ein
kilo mehl und 160 gramm flüssige butter
ich nehme jetzt zuerst einmal das wasser
und werde die hilfe dazu gehen so kannst
du dich super auflösen
[Musik]
ihr kommt jetzt noch der zucker mit dazu
das heißt ich gebe die nachnutzung
aufgehen
und wer diese mischung jetzt abdecken
und dann für etwa 15 minuten stehen
lassen
[Musik]
15 minuten später sieht die hefe so aus
vielleicht warte ja auch beim livestream
mit dabei auf instagram da nämlich willi
telker strategy das aus oder platz der
aber ist nicht explodiert murat hat
irgendwann einfach seine finger mit im
spiel gehabt und dann ist das match
einfach abgeblockt jetzt geht es weiter
mit dem teig ist nämlich dass mehr und
ich muss dazu sagen das ist jetzt eine
große menge das heißt ich mache jetzt
hier raus etwa 24 burger band aber es
ist einfach auch so ihr könnt ihr auch
wenn sie fertig sind gut einfrieren
das bereitet sie einfach auf vorrat und
habe dem welche da und können sie dann
einfach vor dem gebrauch auftauen lassen
jetzt kommen alle zutaten hier mit rein
auch die muttermilch die macht das ganze
richtig schön weich ich möchte ja ganz
reiche bürger brötchen haben dann noch
der zuckerrübensirup der bringt so ein
leicht nussigen geschmack mit rein und
vor allem auf eine schöne farbe in den
teig die zwei eier eier kommende ziel
mit rein weil der teig so ein trio steig
ist das heißt nicht wie normaler
hefeteig bei pizza zum beispiel nur mit
wasser sondern das soll ein bisschen
kuchen ähnlicher sein und dadurch kommt
eben diese leichte und lockerer textur
zustande
ich hätte mir schon und es kann jetzt
schon mal verknetet werden
und an der stelle kommt jetzt auch
gleich die butter betreiben und dann
sollte dem teig für mindestens zehn
minuten lang begleitet werden dann
wieder richtig schön weich und
geschmeidig wird
[Musik]
jetzt ist der teig fertig da ist richtig
schön geschmeidig jetzt fertig meine
arbeitsfläche ein bisschen und gibt dem
teig jetzt drauf
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich den hier zu einer kugel
formen und das ist ein schöner weißer
teig und jetzt hätte ich auch die
schüssel und legten teils hinein und
lassen dann abgedeckt für eine stunde
auf gehen
[Musik]
der teig ist jetzt richtig schön
aufgegangen und jetzt kann ich die
arbeitswelt wir noch ein bisschen fetten
und den teig darauf geben
ich nehme nur die hälfte
jetzt mache ich immer gleichmäßige
portionen ich möchte dass die bürger
bahn sitzt etwa 80 gramm schwer werden
das heißt ich nehme jetzt hier eine
waage und portioniert das ganze
jetzt nehmen sie die einzelnen teig
stückchen und formt sie zu einer kugel
und hierbei ist jetzt wirklich extrem
wichtig dass sie immer dem teig von
außen nach innen mit den fingern formt
so dass wir eine schöne glatte
oberfläche bekommen denn nur dann gehen
die wörter bands richtig gut auf das ist
immer schön von außen nach innen außen
nach innen und dann drehe ich das ganze
um mit diesem zipfel praktisch so und
hab dann sitzen unten und kann jetzt mit
den händen das ganze rund formen
eine variante ist das ganze in der hand
zu machen so oder ihr nehmt auf die
arbeitsfläche und rollt praktisch mit
den händen hier außen rum und so geht
der teig immer wieder nach unten und die
oberfläche wird schön glatt
[Musik]
und sobald die kugel schön rund ist
setze ich sie auf meine back folie und
dann wird das ganze noch mal flach
gedrückt
wenn es dann ein bisschen klebt ein
bisschen mehr drüber schön flach drücken
[Musik]
und dann geht es weiter mit dem nächsten
die band sind soweit fertig ich habe
jetzt eine viertelstunde aufgehen lassen
und im prinzip habe so bissig die
letzten fertig geformt habe waren die
ersten schon gut aufgegangen und damit
sie nicht an trocknen und keine haut
bilden habe ich sie mit folie abgedeckt
und die folie die könnte dann einfach
aufheben und beim nächsten mal wieder
verwenden
jetzt nehme ich ein eigelb und da kommt
jetzt ein bisschen wasser mit rein und
zwar so viel dass es wirklich schön
flüssig wird das heißt es wird jetzt gut
miteinander verrührt
und jetzt werden die teiglinge damit
bestrichen und es muss jetzt aufstehen
flüssig sein damit die bürger später
eben schön weich werden und keine große
größte bekommen
[Musik]
und die betreue ich jetzt noch mit etwas
sesam das gehört für mich auf ein
richtiges bürger brötchen einfach mit
drauf
[Musik]
hinzu kommen die bürger brötchen jetzt
in den vorgeheizten backofen bei 190
grad ober unterhitze für etwa 15 bis 17
minuten
die sollen schön goldbraun werden aber
nicht zu dunkel und nach der backzeit
werde ich sofort flüssige botschaft
rüber streiche und so werden die bürger
brötchen richtig schön saftig kämpfen
[Musik]
jetzt sind die berger wann es fertig ich
muss gestehen das sind die letzten die
wir noch haben denn die anderen geburten
leider schon aufgegessen
das heißt wir um gerade eben draußen
gegrillt und uns richtig leckere
hamburger gegessen
bei uns gab es chili- cheeseburger und
auch bitten waldburger mit leckeren
champignons und da kommen die rezepte
auch demnächst online also ich würde mal
sagen stellt euch jetzt alle in die
küche macht diese leckeren burger bands
und bereitet richtig tolle und leckere
hamburger so und so schwer war es ja
auch gar nicht und falls ihr das rezept
nach machen wollt gibt es dieses auf
sell ist sagte er
da steht es noch mal ganz genau und ich
muss auto zu sagen das sind wirklich die
besten burger waren die wir je gegessen
haben und von daher gibt die bei uns
regelmäßig also bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss mama papa
[Musik]
mama wie papa ring ring in afrika den
veilchen und stark ist mein licht alle
kindersitz ich die mama papa
[Musik]